he's the popular Shawn O'Hara NFL
Network analyst and former Giants
offensive lineman who joins us on the
program you can follow NFL Network
they have good morning football and
that'll be a game day morning I should
say airs Sunday at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on
NFL Network with the popular host Rich
Eisen and Sean joins us now good morning
Sean how's morale top of the morning to
ya Danny so agree man I mean it's just
not the best time of the year
for football and we got golfers talking
trash I love it I love it look when
people say six-pack is funny some people
think I think beer well we were talking
about Brooks koepka was called out by
Bryson to Shambo saying and they went
back and forth about slow play kept cool
kept good has no patience for somebody
who is slow and do Shambo is a work out
guy and then he calls out Brooks kapkan
says hey I don't even think he has a
six-pack Kefka then sends four trophies
from his majors he said you're right I
don't have a six-pack I am too shy of a
six-pack and he shows these four majors
that he's got that's an unbelievable
burn that's unbelievable
that's awesome and Brooks got some pipes
do you know what about the ABS you know
I mean he's he's rocking some smedium
shirts with some dinner and they look
like the old warrior at the sleeve we
were talking about field goals here what
if I said you could get rid of a field
goal you could only have a field goal in
the final 60 seconds of a game or get
rid of it altogether but you have to go
for it on fourth down or punt it so you
get rid of the field goal during the
majority of the game and you can only
use the field goal within the last what
do you say ministy seconds okay last
minute of the game where you have to go
for it or punt that that's your only two
options during the game sure let's see
what happens I mean I tell you what
we're already mad enough at kickers if
they missed a kick but now you're going
to ask a guy kicker to not kick a field
goal for 59 minutes
no pts you're saying no no field goals
nothing and then also they've got to go
and kick one a game winner
yeah like dry ice basically that this
person kick is a game
I doubt kickers will be very thrilled
with that ask Pat McAfee how he feels
what if it was in players vote get rid
of field just get rid of field goals
completely I'm all for it yeah look I
love my I love you my kickers listen I
was a long snapper so I was a part of
the battery high school college I was
the back of long snapper throughout my
NFL career with the Browns and the
Giants so I do love my love some kickers
but yeah I mean I'm I wouldn't be
opposed to just saying look we're either
score a touchdown you go 4-2 or you know
or either get it or you don't like let's
you know let's go back to Rutgers verse
Princeton you know let's let's bring it
back to the glory days 150 years ago
your thoughts when you heard that Luke
Kuechly had retired man I mean the guy's
alive and hopefully he's well but it was
sure felt like like light like that was
it you know I people told me when I was
playing that NFL players football
players died twice you know and and man
I felt I was sad you know I was sad that
we wouldn't get to watch him anymore
I was really my heart ached for him when
I saw the video because I know you know
any NFL player that's ever had to utter
those words I'm gonna retire from
football I mean it's it's hard it's hard
to do it it's hard to watch somebody
else do it
so look I don't really even know Luke
Kuechly
personally but I feel like I do just
from you know watching when the NFL and
that I was painful and it hurt it was
also at the same time a really brutal
reminder of how violent the game is and
how you know how hard it can be
physically when you're taking those
beatings and listen nobody takes a
bigger beating than running backs and
middle linebacker well your job your job
calls for a collision on every play as
you know you being an offensive lineman
your collisions are tighter you're still
having a collision you know the
linebacker is he's
looking for contact not not the other
you know not a lot of other positions
are going blind looking for a car crash
here and I did talk to a hall-of-fame
defensive player yesterday who said in
the last year and a half Luke Kuechly
was not bringing the contact that he
once did that he was trying to play
differently and that's when it's time to
retire because you know that that's just
not who you are and I think that Luke
Kuechly realized that that you know what
I don't need to have a collision on
every play but that's the position I'm
playing in so I wasn't surprised I
watched a couple plays this morning
actually just kind of you know from this
seat and and I think it seemed like
there were times where he would come up
and early on in his career he made that
tackle and did anything twice about it
and there were times this season just
from watching a couple plays that it
seemed like he was hesitant to come up
and and run through the tackle like he
had before and if that's showing up on
film imagine what's going on in his mind
at that moment is coming up to make the
tackle do I turn my head to the right do
I turn to the left I don't want to you
know I'm he was trying to say to protect
himself from the concussions and it was
clearly affecting his play so you know
the one thing we know about those and
you actually used the proper word
because people say football is a contact
sport it's not a contact sport
basketball is a contact sport football
is a collision sport and the collisions
what we know now which we didn't know 10
15 years ago collisions are cumulative
and though those impacts they add up and
it's not just one hit that creates the
damage it's the cumulative effect but
how do you know you're okay Sean um I
don't you know I mean if you ask my wife
she'd probably say I'm not but do you
care to know if I said you could find
out because I know that you can't I
don't know if they can test for CTE yet
while somebody's still alive but you
know how concerned are you about you
know the aftershocks you know I'll say
this there's much more concern on the
other end you know once you've retired
and you start to take assessment of you
know what you just put your body through
you know you start just kind of thinking
about long-term and you know look I'll
say this there are many 27 28 year olds
in any in any workforce that are
thinking about boy how am I gonna feel
when I'm 40 you know I mean that 27 28
people are grinding away you know trying
to make a career for in some way shape
or form so you're not thinking about
that long term but it's it's definitely
a thought and then when you retire from
football you start thinking about man
you know all sudden my back is really
bothering me and it's like you know what
okay all those years of you know doing
this or that it has a cumulative effect
I think the brain aspect of it we have
all changed the way that we think of it
now something you might just say well
you know yeah I forgot my keys or you
hear guys talking about
look I've you know I've got some anxiety
issues or I'm having mood swings I used
to just be well you know you're just you
know you're just getting crotchety and
you're you know you're just a dad with
three kids but now it's you know you
kind of start thinking alright is this
more and I think as a player I think
sending guys to the doctor to find out
what's going on upstairs that's tough
that's a tough conversation but I do
think that now with medicine and and
there are ways that you can try to you
know help the brain heal if you are
suffering from CTE or if you're showing
early signs of this stuff there are
things you can take their supplements
there are procedures and things that you
can do to kind of help regenerate some
of that tissue so I would definitely be
an advocate for trying to find out how
we can help that out and try to find
some improvement there he's Sean O'Hara
NFL Network analyst and won a Super Bowl
with the Giants you were there when Eli
got to the Giants after saying that he
did not want to play for the Chargers we
were wondering if your Joe burrow would
you say and you got one shot at this
would you say to the Bengals I don't
want you to draft me well that's a great
question I think Carson Palmer would it
would have some really good insight on
that I mean they forced him into
retirement then he came back to play for
the Raiders so that tells you all you
need to know yeah I mean look I
Eli took a lot of heat and I'll say this
if you didn't have an older brother
named Peyton Manning and
didn't have a dad and Archie who had
been in the league for a long time I
don't know that he would have had that
Flex you know it'll be interesting to
see how how Burroughs handles that but
you know look I think you look at the
Bengals and and the one thing that I
would have a conversation with is let me
talk to the coach let's find out where
we're headed because that could be a
determining factor in it and that that
whole move why didn't they go after the
quarterbacks coach at LSU Joe Brady
who's now the offensive coordinator at
Carolina if you're if you're all in make
it a package deal and say to Joe burrow
this is we want to make sure that you're
comfortable when you get here and the
transition is easier money well they are
cheap I know but that's it when you ask
a question about the Cincinnati Bengals
99 times out of 100 but that's another
reason not to go there Shawn it is and
you know but I will say this you know
the given number one pick that that
contract is gonna get done you know
you're going to get paid you know it's
it's the next contract what are you
doing after that but you know that
that's you know pretty much slotted
nowadays you know rookies what they make
you know whether you're the first pick
or the fifth pick or the 10th pick
you're you're not you're in a you've got
some guidelines as far as where you're
gonna be so they don't really have a say
in that but I would say you know there's
something to be said for that
organization and just you know look do I
want to do I want to spend my career
there you know and if he's got a chance
to try to make a move and somebody's
willing to make a trade up for him by
all means go for the team that has the
best chance of pulling off the surprise
on the road is Tennessee or Green Bay
Green Bay Packers
yeah I spent a little time this morning
Dan watching that that game from earlier
this year it was week 12 and you know
and when you kind of think about that
game everything man they got run out of
there and you know the 49ers just
destroyed him you know I saw some
different things this morning when I
watched that game I saw three drops in
their first three possessions
I saw Aaron Rodgers on the very first
third down looked like he had never seen
a simple nickel Sam bliss before
and he panicked and he ended up fumbling
the ball they basically spotted the
49ers seven points after their first
drive they're down ten nothing and I
think the wheels fell off early on them
and they could never get back on the
bike I absolutely expect to see a
different Packers team going out there
this Sunday and I expect it to be a
different game this one's going to come
down to the end it's not going to be a
blowout I know the 49ers defense is
pretty darn good
this Packer defense there for their
front rush might be better
Siderius Smith and Preston Smith have
been unblockable a time so wait you
think it's better than the Niners passer
I think they're there their passwords
can be but I think Jerry Smith might he
might he's the most disruptive player in
the league right now he's more
disruptive than Bosa you know I think
when if you look at the 49ers across the
board they're probably more talented but
I think when you look at the way the
Green Bay Packers are playing up front
right now it's you know you can make an
argument that they're playing better
than the 49ers the one thing that I will
say about this 49ers front they had six
sacks against the Vikings all six of
those sacks came on a four-man rush
I know if you can do that yeah I'll
forget about it the boys back there look
Richard Sherman's bat patting himself on
the back guess what sure you're a great
player but with those guys aren't doing
what they're going in front and you look
you don't look as good
so I thinking if they can get pressure
with those front four and not at the
blitz it will be a long day for Green
Bay I'll leave you with this Derrick
Henry when he runs when he builds up
that head of steam there are players who
don't want to tackle him and it's kind
of creative and how they go about trying
not to tell you just don't want to feel
that the Giants had Brandon Jacobs who
was probably similar size to Derrick
Henry what is that like though to have a
physical presence like that where you
feel like defensive players are gonna go
oh god is just gonna hurt when I tackle
him yeah I love that you brought up
Brandon because he's the first guy I
think about whenever i watch Derrick
Henry and it's funny because every week
everybody wanted to try Brandon Jacobs
oh yeah come on Big Boy bring it I'm
coming you know a first quarter chat
also in the third quarter you don't hear
the chatter
people are diving out of the way they're
trying to finally all man I missed my
gap all of a sudden man safeties don't
want to insert in the second half I
wonder why that is
did you see it weekend a week out with
Derek Henry every single week people say
well we got to stop Derek Henry what are
we going to do well Dan how many times
have you said load the box or heard load
the box bring eight guys in the box
guess what Derek Henry has faced more
eight-man boxes this season than any
running back in the game and he's still
getting it done so he's wearing him out
and people don't want to come up and hit
the guy you know Brandon Jacobs we
should tell them all time but be patient
in the first second quarter everybody's
gonna kind of they're gonna come try to
take your legs out he used to wear these
big oversized thigh pads like Earl
Campbell because he knew guys are going
to try to take him out locals they
they're not going up high they don't
want to go upstairs and get and get
embarrassed but by the third and fourth
quarter
those dogs weren't parking at all the
one story that comes to mind is in 2008
we were kicking ass and taking names and
we started out 11 to 1 that was the most
fun year I've ever had a playing
football and Brandon Jacobs was a huge
part of a him Bradshaw and Derrick Ward
we called him Earth Wind and Fire but
I'll never forget we had rushed for 200
yards I think maybe two weeks in a row
and our next opponent was the Baltimore
Ravens and Ray Lewis came out on a
Wednesday and said well they're not
going to rush with 200 on us well I'll
be damned if we didn't bust that
you-know-what and the first play of the
game Brandon Jacobs cut back ran for 56
yards on the very first play of the game
and I've never talked so much trash in
my life as an O lineman in that game but
because people were talking about how
we're gonna stop him and slow him down
we were so motivated and we were we wore
everybody out that day Jared Johnson Ray
Ray all of them they didn't want any
part for Brandon Jacobs Sean great to
talk to you have a good weekend and we
appreciate your time as always I
appreciate it boys I'm going to work on
my six-pack it's Shawn O'Hara an NFL
Network analyst and NFL gameday morning
that'll be Sunday at 9:00 a.m. Eastern
on NFL Network for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on Br
five or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]